jacques cheminade est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous dans le cadre de cette
campagne officielle qui vous permet donc
de faire valoir vos thèses monsieur
chemine à d et vos idées vous d'étonner
on peut le dire dans cette campagne
présidentielle d'abord en prétendant
être le seul à relever aujourd'hui les
défis intérieurs et internationaux on
verra si cette émission est une
rencontre d'une du troisième type car
l'espace et sa conquête authorhouse et
du deuxième type de deuxième team qu'est
ce que vous voulez dire que vous êtes à
ce gros émoi alors troisième type je
parlais de l'espace et sa conquête un
qui est au coeur de votre engagement
politique et de votre parti solidarité
et progrès frédéric dumoulin de l'
agence france-presse et puis perrine
tarneaud de public sénat me rejoindront
tout à l'heure pour vous interviewer
c'est pas toujours un exercice facile
vous le savez pas ce qu'il faut
comprendre vos réponses certains vous
décrivent déjà sur orbite ce semi nahd
non je suis tout à fait sur terre et je
crois je vois mieux le dans le jeu et de
la désintégration du système financier
et monétaire international la
décomposition de l'europe et le risque
de guerre qu entraîne toujours des
situations de ce type à l'avenir
très bien alors vous essaierez d'être
clair dans vos réponses parce que on va
les énarques sont pas toujours très
claire alors les énarques dissidence
c'est parfois plus dur encore c'est
votre cas un énorme je crois être très
clair pour les mamans qui écoute qui
savent ce qui leur tombe dessus
alors j'ai vu que certains journaux ont
renoncé à vous poser la moindre question
c'est le cas du journal le monde c'est
la mise à l'index vous savez beuve méry
disait dans les années 30 qui condamnait
et la pourriture de la presse j'espère
que ça se reproduit pas aujourd'hui ce
mise à l'index est une injure faite au
pluralisme politique de faire ça et à m
elle intègre à votre personne qu'on
associe toujours à certains mystères qui
perdure à des journalistes du monde
était tellement bon tellement excellent
sachant tous les meilleurs du monde
comme il se prétend le même
j'aurais quand même que pour quelqu'un
de simple comme moi izri vraies plus ou
moins me situer mais il semble que non
que ça les dépasse
on va parler de la finance évidemment
vous aviez effectivement annoncé avec la
crise financière de 2008
il ya des années un vous aviez déjà
dénoncé les dérives
de la finance internationale de wall
street de la city mais d'abord je vois
dans votre programme et dans votre livre
programme que vous voulez réenchanter la
france grâce à la musique alors
décrivez-nous l'action de ces brigades
d'interventions artistiques soir aux
orphelins ce sont des gens les petites
mains symphoniques symphonique
ce sont des gens qui sont aussi deux
drapeaux ce qu'ils sont des gens
organisés pour mettre la musique à
l'école et des enfants qui ont cinq mois
musique sont très capables d'être sur
une scène et de jouer de petits morceaux
donc que des michel serres qui est très
intéressant il dit le coeur et le modèle
réduit de la société idéale
moi je crois aussi c'est pour ça je
pense à la potence music le coeur le
coeur le grand choral
les gens voient leur voix puis voix la
voix des autres dans le même registre
puis voit les autres juste de voix puis
voile groupe et ils voient que
finalement ce qu'on chante et d'être
chose qui dépasse complètement là
l'addition la voix des uns des autres
quelque chose de beau donc cette beauté
fait en commun créer un état d'esprit un
état d'esprit positif et où on a le sens
qu'on peut réussir dans la vie et qu'il
faut se battre collectif auto dans tous
les collectifs et non non non on chante
mal oui c'est pour le dévouement pour
les autres mourraient pas parler de vos
brigades d'interventions artistiques
variées gâte c'est des gens de ce milieu
là qu'on en voit un peu partout dans les
rôles un peu partout faire chanter les
quatuors prochain chez ceux ci dans le
sait trop dans les gares partout mais en
commençant par l'école et en commençant
par des gens qui s'intéressent vraiment
à la musique classique c'est les foules
en donner aux enfants les réalisations
le plus belle la culture universelle
alors il ya quelqu'un qui l'a fait au
venezuela s'est reçu un tony abreu et en
france il ya des gens qui cherchent à
s'en inspirer à faire un effort dans ce
sens c'est bien avant chanel à soho
d'accord d'accord alors tous les cas
votre petite musique se glisse dans la
campagne officielle je le disait jacques
cheminade vos mots vos concepts le
nouveau visage du fascisme pour vous
c'est donc wall street et la city de
londres c'est quelque chose qui pratique
une politique de purge de saccage social
donc qui crée les conditions d'un chaos
dans la société quelque chose
extrêmement dangereux et vous savez que
rex c'est moi le premier qui avait parlé
dans cette campagne rex a prévu ce que
c'est le plus le plus grandes agences
aux produits financiers dérivés c'est à
dire de paris sur les prix futurs de
tous et ils ont aimé ce qui s'appelle un
contrat à terme sur la dette de l'état
français elle sortira ce produit le 16
avril
donc c'est pas un hasard c'est à dire
une pression mise sur le président le
futur président de la république alors
c'est pas cher mais voilà ça va être
lancé sur le marché de francfort
oui c'est bien cela dans quelques autres
bourses qui sur le marché européen des
produits dérivés est donc un contrat à
terme sur les obligations françaises
ce qui fait qu avec 50000 euros on peut
jouer sur un million d'euros parce qu'il
ya un son à fait d'un effet de levier de
20 on peut jouer vingt fois sa mise au
point d'instruments spéculatifs contre
la dette française je vois que jean luc
mélenchon ailleurs s'est emparé
également de ce combat aya reprises que
je disais moi j'avais parlé à trois
jours donc publiquement
donc c'est vrai alors jean-luc mélenchon
vous dire assez contre la gauche ce qui
est vrai c'est contrôlant lorsque l'on
hollande a parlé de combattre son
principal adversaire qui le monde de la
finance
il a dit qu'il fallait séparer les
activités bancaires moi je vais beaucoup
plus un sou pas le combat ne peut pas
être mené à moitié mais c'est contre
hollande mais c'est aussi contre sarkozy
s'il est élu c'est contre la france et
contre les états nations parce qu'entre
notre dette
pas seulement contre notre dette contre
la résistance au démantèlement financier
que peuvent représenter les états
nations et la politique des états
nations tous d'agir dans les aliments de
passer spéculateurs est ce que nous ne
sommes pas les premiers responsables de
ce qu'il nous arrive je termine un
responsable c'est eux qui ont réalisé
les démarches et de paris la dette
mais il ya autre chose on joue ce qu'on
mange on joue sur ce qu'on mange on joue
sur les produits alimentaires sur le blé
sur les matières premières
on joue sur ce qu'on respire c'est le
droit la pollution on joue même sur la
vie puisqu'on joue ce rapidement et en
titrisant des assurances vie en jouant
sur ça donc il ya tout un jeu qui se
fait sur des choses laquelle on devait
absolument jamais joué il faudrait
l'interdire
pour ça il faut un accord international
parce que sur l'interdît en france ce
sera fait à londres sur un terrain
ça sera fait aux états unis et c'est
donc il faut une autre politique
fanny frites et que c'est un autre
système carrément vous prenez système et
à notre système est un projet une vision
différente de l'actuelle qui
s'autodétruit on est un système qui est
inquiet de votre singularité parce qu'il
est apte candidat a sa vérité
ils disent ces trois jours ou en tous
les cas pas tout à fait comme vous mais
qui disent qu'il faut maîtriser et les
marchés financiers vague tout le monde
joli joli c'est vague et c'est un peu
gnangnan excusez moi mais moi je dis il
faut d'abord organisé en france selon le
président ne peut pas faire mais qu'il
faudrait organiser une commission d
enquête parlementaire
comme roosevelt l'avait fait avec les
corps en 1933 pour voir où en est la
question de la dette en france et les
banques et de la crise financière la
connaît quand même peu non on sait pas
ce qu'il ya dans les 500 milliards hors
bilan bnp paribas je lis toujours parce
que c'est un exemple particulièrement
frappant on sépare ya des effets
toxiques probablement c'est pas très
joli et bnp paribas avait jusqu'à il ya
quelques mois seulement 3% de capitaux
propres par rapport à sens d'engagement
financier s'est pas beaucoup
c'est ce qu'avait lehman brothers
s'avança crise donc on est dans une
situation toutes les banques se trouvent
dans un état
disons instable extrêmement instable et
elles veulent de l'argent pour se
renflouer
alors on leur donne on à la banque
centrale européenne a émis d'abord 489
milliards en décembre puis 529 points 5
milliards en février
un pour cent sur trois ans c'est
pratiquement un cadeau mais que font les
banques
est-ce qu'elles se prêtent entre elles
n'ont pas confiance est ce qu'elles font
du crédit aux ménages du crédit aux
entreprises
non ils n'ont pas confiance en
l'économie donc elles vont replacer une
partie de cet argent pas tous une grande
partie auprès de la banque centrale
européenne donc les intérêts en filant
threat oui leur prête à la banque
centrale européenne qui est la perte à
verte
c'est à dire ça soit un peu un portage
négatif et ses 1 % elle replace à 0,25
et qu'elles sont en perte de 0 75
maisons refuge
elles ont cherché un refuge en attendant
une situation plus difficile pour elle
c'est à dire qu'elle veut pas
d'engagement parce que elle pourrait pas
disposer cet argent tout de suite que
pensez-vous de l'expression banks terre
vous connaissez non je n'aime pas ces
experts
ça a été utilisé au gangster pression là
non parce que sont pas les banques ni
les banquiers c'est l'ensemble du
système qui est un système pousse au
crime
vous serez destruction c'est le système
qu'il faut changer plus que d'hommes
encore qu'est ce qu'on fait des banques
demain sous votre règne en garde en
dégagent les banques de dépôts et
crédits bien sûr il est faux nécessaire
à l'économie
et si elles font mal si elles prennent
trop de frais de recouvrement tuer le
pré sur par des agios par des frais sur
les mouvements de compte les clients en
les menaces nationalisation mais pour
l'instant il faut les laisser opérer
celles qui servent l'économie vraiment
et les autres ceux qui ont spéculé ces
ont spéculé elles ont gagné tant mieux
pour elles elles sont perdues faillite
ordonnée faillite réguler faillite
contrôlée
que répondez-vous à françois fillon qu'à
lille dans une interview cette semaine à
la vie déclare si les financiers ont
tant d'importance aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'on s'est endettée les états ne
sont pas obligés de se mettre sous leur
coupe c'est une mystification que de
faire croire à un complot international
de financiers ce n'est pas un concours
international de financier c'est un
système qui fonctionne comme cela et je
prends que françois fillon a beaucoup de
culot il avait dit il ya quelques temps
que les caisses étaient vides elles ne
l'ont pas été puisqu'on a avancé de
l'argent aux banques
j'en accepte avec la centrale la banque
centrale européenne une autre par là
dedans de faire ces avances aux banques
donc d'une part et d'autre part c'est
vrai que les états ont accepté de perdre
le contrôle de leur dette
c'était le 3 janvier 1973 la fameuse loi
qui a dit que la banque de france vous
faire d'avancis d'acheter les
obligations du trésor et on s'est livré
aux marchés les banques naturellement
prêter aux états à taux d'intérêt
supérieurs à ceux auxquels les
empreintes et ils ont fait de bénéfices
sur le dos des états les états sont
endettés et aux influences et les grands
travaux au lieu de financer des
investissements d'avenir
les états c'est vrai on se sont rapides
et clientèle ont financé la consommation
et on sont tombés eux aussi dans la
facilité c'est toute la crise des
subprime aux etats unis
alors vous considérez donc qu'on peut
dominer la finance on peut un peu on
peut pas la dominante par l'expression
j'utiliserai non j'aime pas ces
expressions de l'événement
aujourd'hui je serais dominer l'entier
en animé et la contrôler et être le
cerveau ne pas être débordé dans la
finance à être débordé et dire à michel
pébereau qui n'est pas le chef d'état en
france
parce que michel pébereau susurre à
l'oreille des puissants et puis
s'ensuivent demain il faut arrêter ça on
a besoin des banquiers vous l'avez
rappelé en a besoin des bons tiers et le
bon banquier
on n'a pas besoin des banquiers qui
mélange l'investissement qui mélange le
dépôt qui est un mélange de crédit et
qu'ils ont des liens avec le monde de la
city et de wall street
on a une situation actuellement en
france de monopole financier si vous
prenez toutes les sociétés du cac 40 bnp
paribas a des représentants dans 47% des
conseils d'administration c'est ça
l'économie libérale est ce que vous
sentez je ne sais pas l'adhésion sur vos
thèses monter au cours de cette campagne
oui il ya beaucoup d'intérêts sur cette
analyse et il ya beaucoup d'intérêts sur
éventuellement le solution c'est fou
revenir à du crédit public comme on
avait après la guerre comme on a eu la
croissance et le développement pré vert
là non plus pas d'epargne mais qu'est ce
qu'on avait on avait un crédit qui était
un pari sur l'avenir
on l'a fait c'est l'expression louis
armand et des autres de planificateur de
l'époque fourastié les libère bout les
philippe lamour tous ces gens là avaient
un sens de l'avenir
ils ont joué ils ont gagné on a fait la
france aurait guère qui était votre sens
de l'avenir parce qu'ils vous portent
très très très loin
aussi loin que la planète mars on va en
parler dans un instant avec frédéric
dumoulin
si vous sentez vos idées monter dans
l'opinion en tous les cas vos militants
ne sont pas si nombreux que ça on parle
de 2005 mais quand il s'agit de les
rencontrer et bien les médias tombe
toujours sur le même c'est l'expérience
vécue par julien cholin que vous ce pas
vrai propose de suivre ou réagir et
apporter à paris reconnaissez un petit
peu cheminots way
le militant qu'on montre aux
journalistes c'est lui c'est fabien la
vingtaine ça fait deux ans qu'il a
quitté ses parents à rennes pour se
dévouer corps et âme à son candidat
il est candidat à la présidentielle ils
indépendants
on vient on vient lever une armée de
citoyens
voilà on est on est 2 2 sur le marché
peut-être une dizaine en ile de france
pas facile de savoir combien ils sont a
porté la parole de jacques cheminade
en tout cas ils sont à temps complet
fabien a tout lâché pour la
présidentielle mais il jure qu'il n'est
pas rémunéré par son parti selon lui
tout est question d'organisation
moi je suis en colocation avec d'autres
militants il y en a ils sont ils ont
leur propre appartement ils se
débrouillent comme ils peuvent
certains sont qu'à mi-temps des membres
dévoués un fonctionnement étrange et un
gourou américain controversé solidarité
et progrès était déjà soupçonné en 2007
de dérives sectaires
pas de quoi effrayer les 500 maires qui
ont fait de jacques cheminade un
candidat à la présidentielle alors
aujourd'hui sa marque de fabrique c'est
son projet d'extension spatiale
d'industrialiser la lune et explorer la
planète mars
tout un projet de société pour karel de
week-end aujourd'hui les 110 l'espace je
connais pas ça va utiliser un portable
ça marche comment un portable ça marche
avec des satellites dont vous êtes dans
l'espace
on va rien industralisés la france ont
choisi en choisissant les hautes
technologies
oui le parti à ses obsessions la finance
la lune mais aussi barack obama ou la
reine d'angleterre trafiquante de drogue
la banque qui gère la fortune de la
reine a été l a été
disons mise en accusation d'avoir
blanchi de l'argent voilà une accusation
effectivement porté sur la banque banque
britannique pas forcément la reine
d'angleterre elle-même cette banqueroute
ce qui a été la banque la monarchie
britannique depuis toujours et qui
étaient épinglés maintenant mais ceux ci
demandaient un chinois d'où vient une
partie de l'argent du stand de la
monarchie britannique pas la grande
bretagne et vous répondra guerre de
l'opium
frédéric dumoulin van soir j'en ai 60
ans presqu'île qui brûle
envie de vous poser des questions
précises donc en fait quand on parle de
vous un petit peu aux gens dans les
dîners etc
les gens disent ah oui monsieur chemine
adam fait c'est le monsieur qui se
présentent un qui qui veut se présenter
aux présidentielles
en fait on entend parler de vous
uniquement la présence y est alors
pourquoi miser uniquement sur cette
élection
ce dans les dîners on à l'oreille aux
choses qui sont dans la presse et dans
le milieu est abolie en fait pas trop
attention à ce qui se passe dans la rue
on a une liste en bretagne à une
élection régionale 10500 voix 1% c'est
pas si mal pour une première fois
c'était avec seulement 35 euros mais
uniquement bretagne ailleurs et ça on
n'a pas les moyens
le système de financement public de la
politique
le public je pars pas les mallettes et
dévalisent les bongo bongo le système
public est un système dans lequel les
partis en place reçoit 75 à 80 millions
d'euros par an au prorata leurs élus à
l'assemblée nationale et du nombre de
voix obtenues si l'on présentait ce plus
de 50 candidats chacun avec plus de 1%
ce système lasserre les gens en place
ceux qui n'y sont pas ne sont pas servis
on est d'autant plus pour nous comme aux
comptes de campagne aux élections
présidentielles de 1995 interjeté dans
des conditions scandaleuses et quand
elle m'a réclamé le remboursement des
150000 euros aux avances de l'état
vous avez une heure doivent y reviendra
mais c'est une ardoise honorable et
messieurs chirac et balladur ont eu un
avantage qui est un déshonneur pour eux
donc en fait quand on regarde un peu vos
propositions on se rend compte elles
sont assez iconoclaste elle
on a un peu de mal à vous classez parce
que mathieu a pâti m'a dit que c'était
pas mal donc je sais plus quoi penser
banal donc quand même surpris c'est
l'espace tout le monde se concentre sur
l'espace parce qu'on est une société de
l'éternel présent l'immédiat il faut du
résultat tout de suite c'est le profit
financier et on passe pas deux ou trois
générations devant nous à l'époque de de
gaulle de kennedy ou de gagarine
on aurait pensé comme nous pensons mais
donc parmi les candidats donc les veaux
neuf concurrents on sait à peu près les
classer tous sens sur les sur le spectre
politique donc de l'extrême gauche à
l'extrême droite et vous on vous met ou
toujours dit que j'étais gaulliste de
gauche où les gens creuser davantage
dreyfusards donc c'est à dire je n'aime
pas qu'on tape sur le prix mais est ce
que je voudrais l'engin pas du ver
gauche non plus ce gaulliste vous dire
quelque chose très spécifique 1940 alors
il s'est élevé au-dessus de ses attaches
familiales de son histoire
pas tellement puisque il est adhérent
jeunes républicains des premiers abonnés
le septième à beaune et j'aimerais plus
qu'avant la guerre qui était la gauche
chrétienne mais quand on reprend
lisandro 240m un dess 10 juin 1954 et de
18 juin et quand on voit en fait dans
l'historie des élections présidentielles
je crois qu'on 81 vous aviez appelé à
voter mais pour monsieur giscard c'est
pas moi c'est le parti qui avait appelé
à voter jusqu'à moi
dans le secret de l'urne j'ai pu voter
ni pour l'un ni pour l'autre je voter
blanc déjà et en 2007 vous aviez voté
pour moi un moyen louis aux premiers
sont tous et cette fois ci pour monsieur
hollande vous voulez me rends compte que
c'est pas sûr c'est chez monsieur
hollande hollande vient d'être
interviewé il a dit qu'il était pour la
séparation les activités de banques
d'affaires et banques de dépôts et
crédits mais sous le même toit
il veut pas d'éclatement de banque moi
je pense qu'il est dangereux sont
prendre monde de la finance à moitié on
ne peut pas qu'on ne peut pas faire un
enfant à moitié donc monsieur hollande
s'il ne va pas assez loin
prendre un très grand risque de chaos de
confusion et probablement de recul donc
dans ce cas là je voterai blanc s'il
continue à s'exprimer de cette façon
d'accord mais si jamais vous pensez que
la réaction de nicolas sarkozy peu
et ce serait plutôt bénéfique par
rapport à celle de monsieur hollande
dans ce cas là puisque vous dites qu'il
est assez on veut qu'il est assez fou
qui va pas assez loin monsieur hollande
c'est ça il n'est pas c'est pas un homme
de caractère c'est vrai monsieur sarkozy
c'est un homme de caoutchouc il change
tout le temps il se déforme
il a une certaine résilience de temps en
temps d'autres fois non c'est un homme
qui est réactif et c'est pas un homme
qui est actif il a fait un très bon
discours le 25 septembre 2008 sur le
changement du système financier et
monétaire international le discours de
toulon
will smith toulon je trouvais très bon
mais il a tenu aucune des promesses
qu'il avait présenté à toulon c'est à
dire qu'il a fait le g20 les paradis
fiscaux sont toujours là les sociétés
françaises ils sont toujours il y avait
dit que les paradis fiscaux c'est fini
c'est une citation à pittsburgh ça après
et il a dit aussi que il combattrait et
les dérives du capitalisme financier
je dois constater que le 1er novembre
on a adopté la directive européenne mif
qui permet de constituer les marchés
parallèles tout ce que les anglais
appellent et dans tout ce qu'on appelle
plus poliment les plateformes
alternatives avec toutes les plus
grandes banques qui ont une parfaite
opacité spéculer joue et ça les français
lizarazu question générale gestion qu'il
suffit à comprendre non on nous fait les
poches c'est ça je vais citer nicolas
sarkozy il a eu aujourd'hui un échange
téléphonique avec barack obama pour dire
que
barack obama a dit qu'il est admiratif
devant le combat mené par nicolas
sarkozy que pensez vous je pense que les
deux pratiquent une politique de
planches social et qui s'entendent pour
la pratique et donc ils se sentent en
est à dillon de connivence l'un avec
l'autre mais c'est les etats-unis sont
en train d'être saccagée ont quand même
de comprendre parce que si vous même
vous n'étions vous n'étiez pas candidat
vous vous tourniez riez pour le dr
lequel des neuf candidats des autres
je serai un polémiste qui de façon
ardente m et la pression écrire et
peut-être ce moment là les journaux
prendrai mes articles ce qu'ils ne font
pas maintenant parce qu'ils trouvent
engagés en politique est comme le monde
y pense que si un objet non identifié à
moshi très surpris et je le répète rien
du monde qui sont tellement intelligents
si intelligent et qui ont tellement
d'informations soient incapables
d'identifier quelqu'un comme moi avant
il y avait quand même des propos qui
sont difficilement identifiables si on
parle de venir puisque j'ai lu dans
votre livre encore une fois monsieur
cheminade à propos de votre conquête du
cosmos qui a uni n'ont jamais parlé de
conquête du cosmos et ça c'est l'école
russe le début du 28 mars mars un peu
l'écart en faisant escale sur la lune
oui bien sûr avec vous et que génération
il faut donc explorer industrialisés le
système solaire a une identité terrienne
se substituera une identité
elio systémique et galactique suscitant
à la frontière de nous mêmes ce que nous
portons en nous de plus je me trouvais
la phrase là il est apparemment la plus
jeune un rejet c'est vous mêmes vous
écrire ici la comprendre donc j'avoue
république
oui elle est difficile à comprendre pour
quelqu'un qui n'a pas eu l'esprit
attaché aux programmes spatiaux des
années 50 et 60
aujourd'hui vous savez qu'aujourd'hui on
est en train de massacrer les programmes
spatiaux même ariane 5 eme qui doit
lancer des doigts permettre de lancer
12 tonnes c'est à dire de cette élite on
est en train d'arrêter le programme
quelque chose de très élémentaire et
surtout les programmes à long terme sont
tous arrêtés notre identité r non c'est
vrai que nous avons une identité
terrienne ou en ce sens d'abord c'est
quoi l'identité et diot systémique cloud
et italienne celle qu'il faut sentir
disons en état de sympathie d'empathie
avec ceux qui souffrent bien un milliard
de personnes en france qu'ils mangent en
europe et dans le monde
il ya un milliard personnes en europe 1
dans le monde pardon qui ne mangent pas
à leur faim et un en europe puisque 1 6%
apparemment en ile de france d'après les
derniers sondages
donc il faut leur donner les moyens de
vivre ça c'est la première chose il
n'ira jamais dans l'espace que le résout
pas les problèmes sur terre deux
générations pendant de générer après non
non ça il faut le faire tout de suite il
faut entre autres sous les projetées sur
le mur de la caverne de l'immédiateté
il faut faire une politique du pôle
emploi très vite une vraie politique
je pars sauver la médecine au travail
qu'on aura réglé nos problèmes sur terre
on nous faut le régler une autre
identité du temps voire long actuelle
c'est-à-dire voir ezio sérénité galaxy
veut dire que il faut penser par exemple
qu'on va savoir s'il ya ou pas de la vie
sur des exoplanètes
maintenant on sait qu anna les a
identifiés indirectement si on met un
observatoire sur la lune
y'a pas les perturbations terrestre il
ya moins de gravité bien sûr six fois
moins on peut voir mieux avec des
miroirs et on peut voir plus loin
on utilise les technologies les plus
modernes et on peut voir si l oxygène
l'ozone sur cette exoplanète c'est très
intéressant c'est la vie ailleurs ça
change tout notre conception de l'hiver
on sait pas pour l'instant je peux pas
faire d'hypothèses qui sont déchirés on
trouve de l'hélium sur la lune de
l'hélium 3 très utile pour faire la
fusion thermonucléaire contrôlée des
énergies de l'avenir 40 ou 50 ans donc
c'est demain ou après demain
mais si on veut aller vers demain ou
après demain il faut commencer
aujourd'hui et remettre l'économie sur
les rails de l'investissement à long
terme et du respect du travail humain
ils n'ont pas le cas aujourd'hui sur des
sujets plus terre-à-terre
sujets sociétaux qui ont pu alimenter en
fait la campagne on aimerait savoir en
fait ce que vous en pensez vous puisque
je répète que donc a priori vous êtes
pour le droit de vote des étrangers vous
c'est ça oui on dirait que jean
municipal que connaît mais je suis pour
autre chose et on l'a vu encore plus
important ces courriers des maisons site
du citoyen dans les quartiers populaires
qui regroupe les services publics y
compris avec un interprète donc et un
accès soit créé associé à des maisons du
droit où on enseigne aux gens quels sont
leurs droits et leurs devoirs et comme à
lille s'est fait dans la région de lille
mais il faut le faire beaucoup plus d
une école des parents qui associe les
parents se tuent leurs enfants
et alors on a une intégration et je suis
pour qu'il soit constitué un ministère
de la coopération du co-développement et
les migrations
et quand on enlève l'immigration au
ministère de l'intérieur et qu'on la met
dans un ministère qui soit un ministère
à la fois qu'ils voient les migrations
et l'immigration en même temps pas
seulement l'immigration par ce sens on
sait que vous appréciez beaucoup
monsieur larouche qui qui a des
positions sur l'homosexualité quand même
assez tranché vous vous en pensez quoi
du mariage homosexuel mariage homosexuel
alors je pose la question cette façon il
ya trois choses en ce qui concerne les
homosexuels la première je veux pas
répondre seulement sur la question elle
même
la première c'est le droit donné son
sang on les en privent et ça personne
n'en parle
arrêté du 12 mars 2009 ensuite et moi je
suis pour que tous donneurs de sang plus
donner son sang maintenant il ya les
enfants
est ce qu'un couple sexuelle ou pas
qu'ils adoptent des enfants
moi je suis pour parce que je dis il
faut que les deux parents partagent la
responsabilité vis-à-vis des enfants
quel que soit leur sexe un an le mariage
des homosexuels moi j'ai pas à trancher
sur une question comme ça j'ai mon
opinion je vais pas à trancher c'est le
parlement qui doit trancher en france
dans ce tour notre président le
président parle de tout une question
comme ça c'est au parlement de trancher
c'est par mois mais justement pour le
parlement donc ça veut dire qu'on parle
aussi du chef du gouvernement
donc ça c'est qui votre chef du
gouvernement vous n'aimeriez qui à
matignon si vous étiez je voudrais
mais un économiste et des compétences et
qui est un sens de ce qui se passe dans
l'économie mondiale viennent analyser ce
qui se passe j'en ai mentionné il n'aime
pas mentionné donc ils pensent qu' il
vaut mieux être discret cette saison à
matignon faudrait pas que ce disque là
non après après une fois que j'ai lu
cela bon tir et on est courageux mais
pas téméraire avant d'être avant d'être
élu vous sentez le soufre alors vous
savez il ya des journalistes ou parfois
des politiques qui viennent avec une
machine lancée du soufre et après une
fois qu'ils auront ces musiciens vous
sentez le soufre avant c'est comme ça ça
se passe bon j'avoue le monde lui un
jeune ensemble pas le saut fumière index
on dirait une acquisition ou une époque
on l'effacé et les visages des photos
mais il ne refuse apparemment de vous
interview parce qu'ils ne savent pas
vraiment qui vous a été chéris ils sont
ces gens si intelligents sont incapables
de pas savoir qui je suis allons donc on
se moque du monde ou quoi
je ne sais pas si on a beaucoup appris
sur vous au cours de cette émission sur
certaines de vos idées mais sur vous on
va en parler dans un instant avec
perrine tarneaud car vous êtes toujours
au coeur de certaines polémiques à vous
n'aimez pas ce genre d'interrogations
vous avez encore une question jeu très
direct sur amiens et à dire ma première
expérience en france après la déception
en arrivant pour lui faire mes études
sa politique de la france en algérie
j'ai combattu pour l'algérie algérienne
ni pour l'algérie française bien entendu
ni pour l'algérie musulmane je pensais
qu'il pouvait y avoir si on respecte et
les élites algériennes une politique
dans ton qu'elle s'est pas produite
parce qu'il ya eu dans l'armée française
la destruction des élites algériennes la
fameuse bleuite je trouve ça scandaleux
très bien voilà donc alors un élément
effectivement de votre cursus qu'il
était utile à cet instant précis de
rappeler jacques cheminade merci
frédéric danjou monsieur cheminade je le
disais vous le restez donc mystérieux à
bien des égards
vos références sur votre gourou votre
mentor drik la cité il ya un instant je
suis un cheval il n'a t'elle pas comme
de gaulle disait de mendès france
très bien on va quand même faire un
petit détour par les états unis avant
d'accueillir perrine tarneaud avec tam
tran huy
l'histoire de jacques cheminade c'est
celle d'un ovni sur la planète politique
celle d'un inconnu loufoque parvenu à
deux reprises à rassembler les 500
signatures pour devenir candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
et pourtant sa trajectoire a commencé
très classiquement sur les bancs des
grandes écoles hec l'ena puis un poste
de haut fonctionnaire au ministère des
finances avant de s'engager en politique
avec un slogan désormais très actuel je
pense qu'il ya une idée à défendre qui
est celle que l'économie mondiale est
atteinte par un cancer financier qui
ronge et détruit tout je veux le
dénoncer je veux dénoncer ces
responsables et dire que c'est le
premier sujet politique celui qui pour
être en tête de toutes les
préoccupations des candidats tout aurait
été sans doute différent si jacques
cheminade n'avait pas croisé la route de
l'américain lyndon larouche
cet homme politique qui s'est fait
remarquer par sa constance candidat
cette fois l'investiture démocrate et
par ses déclarations extravagantes
barack obama est l'équivalent
d'alzheimer et comme lui il a accédé au
pouvoir grâce à l' empire britannique
ce type n'était pas qualifié pour
devenir président des états unis
et oui lyndon larouche est donc
également persuadé que l'accession
pouvoir d'hitler a été planifié par le
royaume uni que l'administration bush a
commandité les attentats du 11 septembre
ou encore que l'homosexualité est un
coup du kgb
alors jacques cheminade à sion utile
jusqu'au bout les déclarations de son
mentor
voilà le faut et parfois un peu de vrai
et contre-vérités quelque chose qui est
absolument scandaleux donc je trouve que
ça pour des gens qui n'ont pas lu ce
qu'a écrit larouche et qui ont recueilli
des dossiers qu'on se transmet de main
en main
c'est scandaleux que ça c'est ce qu'il
ya sur ces sur les sites internet
officiels
les crimes poursuit série c'est ce qui
marque lui-même par exemple
l'homosexualité était un coup que je ne
me l'a jamais dit ça qu'est ce qui vous
séduit dans les idées de lyndon larouche
à une chose quand j'ai rencontré m'a
semblé intéressant de rencontrer 1900 la
première fois j'ai rencontré non gelée
vu dans un rayon public jeté à new york
et je cherchais un peu à voir ce qui se
passait aux états unis
donc j'avais été nommé à new york sous
le palais aux états unis vite et déjà
engagé en politique lui était déjà
engagé en politique et moi même j'étais
aux états unis j'aurais voulu aller au
japon en chine
le palais aux états unis je pensais que
c'est la vrai que ça l'esprit donc voilà
aux états unis sur lui et il a une
analyse qui dit qu' il ya une
financiarisation de l'économie et
qu'elle va conduire un désastre on peut
tirer les conséquences jusque là moi je
les tire est aussi c'est l'époque de
beauce qui des mérites n tous ces gens
qui à wall street commençait à faire des
montages extravagants pour utiliser le
terme comme il le mérite
donc c'était très dangereux parce que
c'était le court terme contre le moyen
et le long terme donc 500 pour ses
théories économiques économique mais en
même temps ça je savais et c'est pas ce
qui m'a intéressé vraiment ce qui m'a
intéressé ces théories sur la culture il
disait il se met en place une culture de
l'instant de l'instinct flash et cette
culture de l'instant de l'instinct du
flash un dénominateur commun avec ce qui
se passe dans l'économie sa
financiarisation et le court terme
qu'elle présent les gens nous penserons
moins en moins à l'avenir elles sont
plus en plus dans une société où ils
n'auront pas d'horizon l'ont ils verront
pas avec les yeux du futur
ils seront dans le présent ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que quelqu'un aux
états unis qui s'appelle jean mccarthy
qui était le démocrate qui a combattu
johnson et qui a combattu les gens en
place avait aussi cette idée là au
moment où est ce que ça veut dire que
par exemple il faudrait supprimer
internet les réseaux sont bien sûr que
non tout ce qui est sûr utilise la chose
internet c'est comme les langues
d'europe 1 est le meilleur et le pire
tout le monde vous le dira donc comment
éviter en partie le pire
magnien dans le meilleur moi j'ai jamais
pensé qu'en réprimant le pire en
obtenait de bons résultats ce en faisant
le meilleur c'est pour ça que je défends
toute cette culture classique pas la
française du xviie siècle mais la
culture des grands
son l'humanité à l'école dans la rue
partout
je voudrais qu'il y ait par exemple dans
chaque région à palais de la découverte
avec un planétarium qui est des musées
l'imaginaire un peu partout quand tu
donnes la culture au peuple comme le
voulait léo lagrange ou andré malraux ça
ça coûte un petit peu cher et les
régions et les finances régionales sont
un peu à sec elles sont à sec
parce que on a une société dans laquelle
en les les régions en particulier n'ont
pas de ressources et les dotations de
l'état ont été gelés donc c'est tout un
système qui est le prochain proche nous
mène à aux financiers et à la
prééminence accepter ce qu'on discute
parlais tout à l'heure du financier sur
l'économique
c'est plus l'économie c'est la finance
c'est à dire c'est comment on peut à
court terme gagner plus d'argent
possible en faisant n'importe quoi vous
faire plaisir qu'un puisque vous êtes
souvent contrarié dans les interviews
dans l'émission jean-pierre jouyet
estime que le contrat à terme sur la
dette française dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure à ce produit sur la bourse de
francfort ex voilà le rex un produit
d'une société privée est un mauvais
signal qui nous est envoyée voyez jean
luc mélenchon messieurs juillet d'un
pouce rive alors c'était je trouve que
c'est un signal logique de la part de ce
système
c'est ce système dont il faut qu'il faut
changer le système est en train de faire
les deux choses pour sa survie
c'est comme un lieu sûr ils tuent des
moutons vous à l'évidence et les
états-nations ouailles un peu dans la
peau d'un leader aujourd'hui un éclair à
que nous ferons j'essaye d'apporter une
lumière sur ce qui se passe est montré
comme il peut la voie de l'avenir
bon pour revenir juste aux petits
reportages convient de convient de voir
autour de lyndon larouche il ya quand
même des propos qui peuvent choquer les
gens quand il compare par exemple on
viens de l'entendre
obama à hitler ça vous assumez savoir
propos j'ai expliqué au moins 20 fois et
j'ai pu faire le mieux avec yann barthès
qui était plus honnête et qu'il m'a
laissé le temps de répondre mais là on
entend aujourd'hui pour répondre et si
on regarde avec les yeux 1946 la
comparaison ne peut pas se faire si on
regarde avec les yeux 1934 oui parce que
par quoi les nazis ont commencé des lois
d'exception
en ce qui concerne les libertés
publiques destruction des libertés
publiques aux états unis ça a lieu les
états unis par exemple on au détail en
septembre en tout cas
beaulieu opportunément on a attiré 7
conséquent cela alors que les attentats
du 11-septembre à la véracité des faits
autour de ces attentats si bien sûr je
crois la véracité des faits ça serait
stupide ne pas y croire c'est qu'elle 28
pages dans leur rapport chelbi g
officiel de des sénateurs et des
représentants américains oea 28 pages
qui n'ont jamais été publiés et barack
obama avait promis les publier aux
victimes il n'a jamais fait ça c'est un
des problèmes avec obama c'est pas le
principal mais c'est un reflet d'une
question beaucoup plus générale il n'ya
pas fermer guantanamo il envoie des
drones partout pour tous des terroristes
sont eu deux ou trois terroristes à 20 à
30 civils tant pis un dégât collatéral
ils ont peu selon une nouvelle loi le
dash défense régionale aux états unis
qui vient d'être votée récemment sur la
pression d'obama de l'exécutif
l'exécutif américain peut arrêter
n'importe qui dans le monde sous
prétexte qu'il est complice d'al-qaïda
ennemi d'état américain c'est à dire ça
viole des libertés publiques
et ça c'est déjà en place plus une
politique de santé publique qui est une
politique de triage exactement les des
buts ce qui s'est passé dans les années
33 35 caractérise quand même hitler et
le régime au pouvoir sous hitler c'est
la shoah ce le low cost ou saas et après
avant il ya l'engrenage vous savez ce
que disait le parc arnould l'air il
montrait tous les massacres successifs
du nazisme me disais-je des protestants
jeunes âmes et résister au dernier
moment il ya plus personne pour
protester
donc c'est ce qui s'est passé en
allemagne nazie c'est à dire que pièce à
pièce est une destruction et on en a on
est tous ces gens pour ce qu'ils étaient
on a tué les handicapés physiques et les
malades pour ce qu'ils étaient onze à
avoir privé de soins et qu'ensuite on
les a tuées non non il ya un programme
il a créé une commission pour faire le
tri ya là des gens pensent qu'ils sont
et vous n'aimez pas trop
j'étais malade y aller pour éviter aux
états unis qui décide qui va être
soignées ou pas lorsque je sais pas vous
étonner en dialyse en maladies
chroniques maladies cardiaques et c'est
justement pas lié à une insuffisance
totale de couverture médicale aux états
unis non il est pas si total qu'on le
dit certains avaient des couvertures
médicales bien meilleur cette bombe a
adopté aujourd'hui et vous savez ce
qu'avaient dit les eaux alexander qui
était un jeu mentionne toujours par
c'est très important c'est un médecin
américain qui était expert à nuremberg
question les médecins nazis
il ya des cons chiffres la vie humaine
dès qu'on met un coup à la vie humaine
toutes les dérives les plus terribles
peuvent arriver d'autres barack obama
est en train de faire un génocide aux
états unis en puissance et en mai les
républicains aussi d'accord chacun dans
système américain qui est en train de
s'enfoncer dans quelque chose je sais
pas quand même je sais pas si vous avez
vu le film de don siegel qui est le film
sur l'invasion d'une petite ville par
des gens qui peu à peu occupent les
corps et les gens changent c'est à dire
que jean changement d'un film de science
fiction mais c'est une parabole de du
maccarthysme pas de john mccarthy dont
le parler mais de l'autre et qu'elles
sont passées sur son utilisation
il a pu le sens des réalités mais ce que
vous utilisez vos inspirations avant
lundi la presse américaine non c'est pas
du tout la science fiction
je n'aime qu'un auteur de science
fiction parce que qui s'appelle philip
k.dick quand on reparle aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs pas ce qu'il a dit je décris
les mondes que je décris ce pour qu'il
n'arrive pas et je mets en garde contre
ceux là ont joué ça intéressant comme
manière de présenter les choses alors
que les autres vous mettre en condition
pour peu à peu perdre le sens des
réalités
c'est pour ça que je suis content les
jeux vidéo violents ça a été utilisé
dans l'armée américaine se maintenant
utilisés par les fondamentalistes
islamiques pour mettre les gens
désinhibition du désir de tuer et vous
savez c'est ce qui a été fait en réalité
et je les dis pas ça pas été la cause
mais c'était ce qui crée un
environnement eau meira et regarder des
jeux de décapitation horrible dans le
conflit israëlo palestinien dans les
questions du moyen-orient
donc on est
regardez regardez sigler est en train de
jouer avec le feu
voilà et rien que ça que je dis et
jacques cheminade on a l'impression que
rien ne vous affecte que tout coule sur
vous que vous savez quand les gens
disent des choses qui n'ont pas beaucoup
de sens
ça nous fait voir non pas de vous en
tant qu'être humain de vous en tant que
communicants des choses quand vous êtes
dit que vous avez vu des sujets que vous
avez pas approfondi je comprends qu'un
journaliste n'est pas le temps
d'approfondir les sujets non si je vous
remercie on travaille de temps en temps
quand même
quel est votre programme de campagne là
pour les dix jours qui arrivent
on dit que je n'allais pas faire de
meeting où dit on pas de réunion
publique du tout parce qu'on va faire
c'est un meeting participent active sur
internet vous savez ces méthodes de
david contre goliath
on utilise la fronde et pourquoi pas
organiser de réunions publiques parce
que le coût trop cher d'abord les
expulsés à partir du moment où vous êtes
candidat officiel à la présence d'un
public non les banques le crédit
coopératif et nîmes et rennes nous à
part financer l'avs ans de l'etac 150000
euros
les militants qui ont pu réunir à peu
près 150 à 200 mille euros 350 mille
euros c'est rien mélenchon à 5 millions
les deux grands candidats en plus de 30
millions c'est les sommes d'ailleurs qui
sont le finances publiques a donné au
parti chaque année donc un système en
france de fermeture politique qui
empêche les émergences poutou a très peu
d'argent la tanière contre peu d'argent
le candidat à l'élection présidentielle
quand même et vous parlez d'un système
fermé et je suis très ouvert aux comptes
s'est ouvert en terme et celles à
l'élection ouverte s'est ouvert si vous
avez les formulaire de parrainage rempli
par et mer et à ce moment là c'est
ouvert et il ya une exception si vous
voulez d'autres campagnes sont validés
par le conseil constitutionnel après
l'élection présidentielle vous êtes
quand même rembourser jacques pour moi
c'est ici en effet même les rencontres
sur ce qu'on a pu dépenser peut pas
inventer des choses qu'on dépense il
banques
vous avez tenu comme nous un langage ou
des analyses sur les banques qu'elles
n'aiment pas beaucoup attendront un pas
vous prêtez et en plus c'est banque
française près
et vous allez peut-être mal reçue il n'y
avait pas sur pause entre deux scrutins
présidentiels de ma retraite
c'est notre est mais suffisante pour
vivre pour moi par contre m'appartient
certes l'état laïc au taquet pour se
garantir aux fonctionnaires donc on ne
doit pas être si faible que ça notre
retraite 8150 euros
je suis parti au bout de 13 ans et demi
voilà est un peu notre retraite qu'est
la retraite de tout le monde
plus une troisième retraite qui est une
petite retraite de consultant chez
consultant pour vivoter survivre s'il
fait bien cinq cent mille 150 euros en
tout moi ça me suffit pour vivre très
pensez-vous des signes religieux
ostentatoires selon l'expression mais
réforma j'étais par exemple sur l'acquis
par marine le pen estime que la kippa
n'a pas sa place dans l'espace public
c'est votre avis non parce que c'est pas
tellement stenta thouars on met ça sur
la tête c'est pas tellement au centre at
war un foulard non plus quand on cache
le visage burqa oui parce que la burqa
en cache le visage et moi je partage
tout à fait l'éthique du visage qui
était celle d'emmanuel levinas pour qui
le visage humain est le visage de
l'autre et ce qui vous définit vous êtes
d'accord avec la loi votée par le
gouvernement la majorité actuelle qui
interdit le port de la burqa dans les
lieux publics et andré gerin est un
communiste qui l'avait proposée devrait
justement donc bien d'accord sur ça est
d'accord je dirais laïque
on a l'impression jacques cheminade en
tout cas que vous prenez plaisir à
passer dans les médias à l'occasion de
cette campagne c'est parti ça vous
plaira les gens qu'ils connaissent non
parce que prend plaisir à certains
malades pour défendre des idées pour que
les idées puissent être puisse faire
réfléchir et pour ça il faut un certain
effet choquent un certain défi qui fait
que les gens se rendent compte tout à
coup que leur façon de penser jusque là
était trop dans les choses convenues et
qu'il fallait commencer à faire un
effort pour penser un peu autrement et
voir plus loin
donc c'est ça l'éclaireur c'est ça les
enfants des clae réforme pédagogique qui
m'ont vu tous constatent que je fais un
très grand effort de pédagogie dans les
minutes 30 je suis celui qui est le plus
pédagogue
on voit les autres celle de hollande
c'est vous
blum celle de bayrou ces quatre mesures
qui n'ont pas beaucoup de sens entre
elles et des images il n'y a pas un
approfondissement
j'ai emmené sur cette image vous avez
dit tout à l'heure les malgré les
controverses que vous n'avez pas de
menteur ou de gourou mais vous vous avez
un petit côté gourou non parce qu'en
jouant un jeu qui vous accompagnent du
tous les jeunes reportages des amis sont
assez bien oui
en partie oui c'est vrai et vous savez
pour moi il ya des continuités dans
l'histoire et ce conte unité est une
chose qui m'a scandalisé dans ce
qu'écrit un régis debray quand il dit de
gaulle a inscrit son nom dans le livre
d'or de la france maintenant il est
refermé nous avons nous sommes sortis
l'histoire moi je pense pas du tout la
france n'est pas sortie l'histoire la
france a un rôle d'inspirateur
d'éclaireurs et de catalyseur à jouer et
moi j'essaie de pousser la france à le
jouer
voila voila quand j'ai cru à la france
n'est pas sortie de l'histoire n'espérez
pas tous bords soir